[Musique]
ici la police de les caser tous les
ouvriers sans oublier de sourire vont se
faire identifier ou le monde dont on
réussit elle
les mains noires du corps notre nom
tendu je vais me tuer comment les
gagnants autorisée
les parterres maintenant le visage
contre le sol
j'ai besoin d'un électrique
moi je suis un électrique t'aurais pu
prendre notre contrat démonté dans la
vanne pourquoi on veut savoir avec qui
on colle à mort
[Musique]
ma mère est malade j'ai besoin d'argent
ok on va voir ce que tu peux faire
il est doux et on électrique or il sait
pas à quel point encore d'allumer la
il va falloir que je le tour
comment tu veux vivre talent et ses
parties cachées des pouvoirs oublie ça
et si tu vois quelque chose que tu veux
alors branleur
surveillant électrique qui pourrait être
lié à plusieurs teams déjà exécution
tu t'es retrouvé mêlé à des affaires pas
d'elle
si tu franchis cette fille ne reviendra
pas non non non non si je la perds
qu'elle juge aurait plus rien toute
façon on a un autre contrat pour toi
et tu n'aura qu'une chance
qu'est-ce qu'on fait s'il rate son coup
rivasi je vais réussir
il va réussir
[Musique]
de fait quand même produit